hiérarchie respectée
Voisins-le-Bretonneux accueillait ce
dimanche 30 octobre le sport olympique
de Houilles dernier du championnat de
division indiscret dans ce match en
retard de la 5e journée les vicinois
auront mis moins de 20 minutes pour
marquer sur une erreur de relance des
eaux-villois le numéro 11 de voisin
profite d'une bonne remise de son
coéquipier pour ouvrir le score
[Applaudissements]
5 minutes plus tard ça fait déjà 2-0
pour les locaux un premier tir repoussé
par la barre transversale le numéro 10
n'a plus qu'à pousser la balle au fond
des filets il inscrit même un double et
quelques minutes avant la fin de la
première période bien lancée dans le dos
de la défense de Houilles voisins mène
3-0 à la mi-temps
on a la première grosse occasion qui
peut créer la différence et échanger
l'atmosphère du match après sur deux
contre-attaques on prend deux buts
pendant qu'ils n'ont pas contre le corps
du jeu c'était assez équilibré ce qui
nous manque un peu dense illégalvanisent
en même temps on a fait une super
première mi-temps clairement il y a pas
photo on gagne 3-0 à la mi-temps et le
match il était presque tué et après on
fait un mauvais début de deuxième
effectivement où il démarre mieux la
seconde période des l'entame l'équipe
récupère le ballon au milieu et surprend
voisin le Bretonneux une réalisation du
numéro 10 auvillois pour réduire le
score 3-1 mais les vicinois ne végètent
pas longtemps et inscrivent un quatrième
but à l'heure de jeu d'une frappe lourde
du numéro 7 à l'entrée de la surface où
il sera même réduit à 10 après un coup
de sang de l'un de ses joueurs bien
évidemment expulsé par l'arbitre après
quelques instants de tension à 10
minutes du terme Voisins-le-Bretonneux
enfonce le clou un but marqué au terme
d'une belle action collective très space
conclut par le numéro 8
score final 5 1 pour le
c'est une victoire qui nous fait du bien
parce que c'était un match en retard on
est bien on a fait une préparation
compliquée et au final on est à 3
victoires une défaite donc on est on est
en haut du classement et on a un mois de
novembre très compliqué qui nous attend
donc ça nous de faire le boulot
maintenant on est prêt on est sur une
tendance une spirale très très mauvaise
très très négative il faut vite qu'on
change la spirale pour pouvoir enchaîner
des résultats positifs sachant que dans
ce championnat et rien n'a perdu il
suffit d'enchaîner deux trois résultats
positifs pour se retrouver là-haut donc
nous on va rien lâcher on va travailler
on va pousser pour enchaîner les
résultats positifs grâce à ce succès
voisin grimpe à la quatrième place du
classement et revient à trois points du
leader Limay oui et toujours lanterne
rouge prochaine journée dimanche 6
novembre